[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages
heute mit barbara hahlweg
guten abend schön dass sie dabei sind
wie auch sven voss für den sport auch
von mir einen schönen guten abend und da
sind einige unsere themen
sinkende corona zahlen die
kassenärztliche vereinigung fordert ende
oktober alle beschränkungen aufzuheben
diplomatische krise nach einem
geplatzten opel-deal ruft frankreich
seine botschafter aus den usa und
australien zurück
und großes ahoi auf der interboot am
bodensee feiern die hersteller einen
nachfrage boom
wie geht es weiter in sachen corona
gerade angesichts sinkender zahlen mehr
mut und ein ende alle beschränkungen
ende oktober das fordert heute die
kassenärztliche vereinigung die
gegenrede kam prompt das sei
unvertretbar und gefährlich der blick
auf die aktuelle entwicklung zeigt
anfang juli gingen die zahlen der
neuinfektionen hoch doch seit acht tagen
sinkt die inzidenz wieder auf heute 72
das sei aber kein grund zur entwarnung
sagen experten auch weil das impfen nur
noch schleppend vorangeht die aktuelle
impfquote
62,9 prozent markus wolsiffer hat
details
feiern ohne maske und abstand mitte juli
hatte großbritannien fast alle chor ohne
auflagen zurückgenommen als zeichen des
aufbruchs und genau das fordert nun auch
die kassenärztliche bundesvereinigung
einen deutschen freedom day am 30
oktober mit dieser forderung geht es
eigentlich darum für die menschen zum
einen ein verbindliches datum zu
schaffen und einen impf anreiz zu setzen
sich bis zu diesem datum noch
immunisieren zu lassen
experten warnen jedoch vor zu schnellen
lockerungen obwohl die infektionszahlen
derzeit sinken es handle sich eher um
einen vorübergehenden effekt der brut
zum einen darauf dass die
reiserückkehrer weniger werden dass in
der schule wieder normalität herrscht
und dass verschiedene länder jetzt auch
schon 2g und 3g regeln anwenden der
saisonale effekt war ähnlich bereits
2020 zu beobachten nach einer stagnation
schossen die infektionszahlen im herbst
in die höhe auch dieses jahr könnte es
wegen der kälteren temperaturen so
kommen und wegen der deutlich an stecken
darin variante der virologe martin
stürmer spricht deshalb von einer eher
kurzen verschnaufpause und ich befürchte
wenn wir jetzt nicht massiv wieder aufs
gas getreten was die impfkampagne angeht
oder nicht doch eben anfangen wieder
restriktive maßnahmen im herbst zu
ergreifen werden wir relativ schnell ein
deutliches an fluten auf den
intensivstationen sehen weil aber viele
impfzentren bald schließen fordert der
städtetag noch mehr kreative impfangebot
ohne große hürden gelegenheit mache
impfungen so hauptgeschäftsführer dd das
bedeutet jetzt für die politik dass sie
entscheiden muss ob wir städte das tun
sollen oder ob sie sagen wir können das
ohne euch wir machen das mit den
niedergelassenen ärzten diese
entscheidung muss jetzt getroffen werden
und die muss dann natürlich auch
verbindlich sein die debatte wie
deutschland durch den zweiten corner
herbst kommt nimmt an fahrt auf ohne
eine höhere impfquote so viel scheint
sicher könnten es wieder schwierige
monate werden
in deutschland im herbst schon bereit
für ein ende der korona beschränkungen
welche erfahrungen großbritannien mit
dem freedom day gemacht hat und die
wichtigsten zahlen daten und fakten zu
corona finden sie in unserer zdf heute
das nato verbündete so miteinander
umgehen ist ausgesprochen ungewöhnlich
frankreich hat seine botschafter in den
usa und australien nach paris zurück
beordert grund ist ein geplatzter mega
deal
australien hatte in frankreich 12 diesel
u boote bestellt kosten fast 35
milliarden euro der vertrag war schon
unter dach und fach doch dann macht er
australien einen rückzieher kurzfristig
entschied sich die regierung für atomar
betriebene boote aus den usa küssel hass
zurückbeordert nach paris als zeichen
großer verstimmung der französische
botschafter in australien macht seinem
frust über die vertragskündigung ganz
undiplomatisch luft es ist ein großer
fehler das ist ein sehr sehr schlechter
umgang mit unserer partnerschaft
auch der botschafter in washington wurde
abgezogen das gab es noch nie und darum
geht es australien hat vor zwei tagen
einen seit jahren bestehenden
milliardenvertrag für zwölf französische
ute aufgekündigt und stattdessen ein
sicherheitsabkommen mit den usa und
großbritannien geschlossen als klare
ansage an das chinesische
expansionsstreben im indopazifischen
raum es beinhaltet den kauf von
amerikanischen und britischen
atom-u-boote frankreich ist plötzlich
außen vor einer fonds schönste für das
macht man nicht unter verbündeten und
die unilaterale brutale entscheidung der
usa das ähnelt ja trump methoden
richtung buchs römische tromp heute
morgen dann die diplomatische
kampfansage abzug der botschafter sowohl
australien als auch die usa versuchen zu
beschwichtigen
gerade frankreich ist seit generationen
ein wichtiger partner in dieser und in
so vielen anderen fragen wir werden jede
möglichkeit ergreifen unsere
transatlantische zusammenarbeit zu
vertiefen
ein richtiges versöhnungsangebot ist das
nicht und frankreichs groll sitzt tief
diese krise zeigt us-präsident beiden
setzt geopolitisch andere prioritäten
die eu spielt fast nur noch eine
nebenrolle
das könnte die forderung frankreichs
nach größerer strategischer autonomie
europas weiter befeuern
seit gestern wählt russland ein neues
parlament und es gibt massive vorwürfe
der wahlmanipulation
unabhängige beobachter berichten von
stimmenkauf und einem laxen umgang bei
der bewachung von wahlurnen so seien
etwa stapelweise stimmzettel in die
urnen gestopft worden bis morgen wird
gewählt ein wichtiger stimmungstest für
präsident putin
das us-militär hat eingeräumt bei einem
drohnenangriff in afghanistan vor drei
wochen unschuldige zivilisten getötet zu
haben es handle sich um einen
schrecklichen fehler so der
verantwortliche general bei dem angriff
auf ein auto in kabul seien in der
august zehn menschen getötet worden
darunter bis zu sieben kinder man habe
inmitten der evakuierungsaktion
angenommen die insassen seien
terroristen die möglicherweise einen
anschlag vor hätten die
radikal islamischen taliban schränken
die rechte von frauen in afghanistan
immer weiter ein
mädchen und lehrerinnen werden vom
unterricht an weiterführenden schulen
ausgeschlossen die taliban hatten in
einer erklärung ausdrücklich nur jungen
und lehrer aufgefordert an die schon
zurückzukehren außerdem wurde das
frauenministerium
umgewandelt in ein tugend ministerium
auf der griechischen insel samos wurde
heute ein neues flüchtlingscamp
eingeweiht mit viel geld von der eu und
deutlich besseren sanitären anlagen es
soll ein pilotprojekt sein für andere
griechische inseln allerdings gibt es
kritik von menschenrechtsgruppen das
camp ist schwer bewacht und die menschen
dürfen das lager nur tagsüber verlassen
andreas postel
irgendwie will der stacheldrahtzaun
nicht so recht passend zu diesem
lieblichen eiland in der ostägäis
deshalb wo liegt das neue kämpfer fünf
kilometer weit entfernt von der
touristisch geprägten inselhauptstadt
partie mit eu mitteln finanziert bietet
das sogenannte geschlossene zentrum mit
kontrollierten zugang platz für 3000
menschen die größe entspricht den
neuzugängen der vergangenen jahre und
wir folgen dabei der logik nie mehr das
chaos erleben zu müssen was wir
vorhatten
sauberes wasser sanitäre einrichtungen
klimatisierte schlafräume und sicherheit
das neue camp hat all das was bislang
fehlte im sogenannten dschungel von
samos hausten bis zu 10.000 migranten
unter schlimmsten bedingungen noch abdul
aus dem kongo will hier einfach nur weg
nicht ins neue kämpe aber weiter nach
europa
wir brauchen ein besseres leben wir
stecken hier in der krise das ist kein
alter platz zum leben
samos ist die erste insel in der
ostägäis die nun über ein neues lager
verfügt weitere sind auf den
nachbarinseln wie zb lesbos und kios
geplant über 120 millionen euro hat die
eu dafür vertraglich zugesichert
griechenland habe in der vergangenheit
bereits eine unverhältnismäßig große
last des migrations problems geschultert
und es werden neue flüchtlinge aus
afghanistan erwartet
kritik kommt von ärzte ohne grenzen auch
wenn die menschen das camp täglich
zwischen 8 und 20 uhr verlassen können
fühle sich an wie ein gefängnis wie als
msf 10 tatsächlich ist es ein gefängnis
die menschen haben sicherlich die
möglichkeiten mal vor die tür zu gehen
aber wohin sollen sie gehen auf samos
ringt europa weiter um einen würdigen
umgang mit migration an seiner
außengrenze in der ostägäis
ein weiteres flüchtlingsdrama findet
derzeit an der grenze zwischen usa und
mexiko stadt nordhausen inzwischen über
10.000 menschen unter einer brücke über
den rio grande
die meisten von ihnen stammen aus haiti
die versorgungslage ist katastrophal und
die behörden rechnen mit tausenden
weiteren migranten der örtliche
bürgermeister hat dringend hilfe aus
washington angefordert
nach china dort sind viele menschen
aufgewühlt fürchten um ihre ersparnisse
und auch die finanzmärkte sind in heller
aufregung grund ist der private
immobilienriese ever grant das
unternehmen hat schulden von mehr als
300 milliarden us dollar und steht vor
der pleite nun liegen alle hoffnungen
darauf dass die chinesische regierung
eingreift stefanie schöneborn
diese bilder will china nicht haben
menschen protestieren im südchinesischen
shenzen in dem gebäude des
immobilienriesen ewa grant sie rufen
gebt uns unser geld zurück
eva brand ächzt unter einer schuldenlast
von 300 milliarden dollar innerhalb von
drei monaten verloren die aktien 75
prozent an wert menschen wie sie haben
ihre gesamten ersparnisse in den kauf
einer wohnung investiert jedoch gar
nicht gebaut wurde wenn sie mir mein
geld nicht zurückgeben springe ich hier
gleich vom haus sie haben mich um mein
ganzes geld betrogen ich habe nichts
mehr
die immobilienblase chinas gehört mit
zum wirtschaftserfolg des landes evo
grant ist ein teil davon insgesamt 1,4
millionen immobilien müsste event noch
fertigstellen banken zulieferer
handwerker und privat investoren zahlten
im voraus über grant baute mit schulden
und kann die nicht mehr zurückzahlen der
staat hat viele möglichkeiten
einzugreifen aber es geht ja auch darum
dass man signalisieren will dass der
staat nicht immer zur rettung kommt dh
ich gehe weiterhin davon aus dass es zu
einer zerschlagung kommt dass teile der
der schulden auch nicht zurückgezahlt
werden aber dass man einen
unkontrollierten zusammenbruch des
unternehmens vermeiden will es zeichnet
sich immer mehr ab dass die chinesische
regierung an ever grant ein exempel
statuieren will die aggressive
schuldenpolitik des unternehmens soll
als warnung für alle anderen gelten
zurück nach deutschland
hier haben auch im zuge von corona viele
ihre liebe zum wasser entdeckt die wird
dann beim stand up paddling ausgelebt
oder im urlaub auf dem motorboot oder es
geht gleich ins schwimmen de home office
die nachfrage ist so groß dass die
bootsbauer nicht hinterher kommen heißt
es zum start der wassersportmesse
interboot am bodensee sandra susanka
heimische gewässer erleben seit corona
einen regelrechten boom immer mehr
wassersportbegeisterte legen sich ein
eigenes boot zu und hier geht der trend
zu immer mehr komfort selbst auf
kleinstem raum
das platzangebot
den endkunden so üppig wie möglichen
stadtmusik hier ganz eine tolle
ausfahrbare plattform badeplattform die
irrsinnig viel platz hinter dem steuer
rädern generiert das sind mehr als vier
quadratmeter viel ps ist weiterhin
gewünscht aber auch das thema
nachhaltigkeit spielt eine größere rolle
boote aus langlebigen aluminium
elektrischer antriebe groß ist die
nachfrage lang die wartezeiten bis zu
zwei jahre schuld sind unterbrochenen
lieferketten
aus asien kommen
deshalb sind die verkaufspreise schon
jetzt bis zu 10 prozent höher als vor
corona home office könnte schon bald zum
board office werden dank
glasfasertechnik im hafen
und wer jetzt eine lösung über kabel
haben so dass jeder einfach stabiles
dauerhaftes internet hat auch neu das
fliegende wasser fahrrad nach spätestens
sechs pedal umdrehungen soll man damit
abheben können mit ein bisschen übung
auch in diesem jahr für das oktoberfest
in münchen aus wegen corona als trost
feiern viele gaststätten heute eine
wirtshaus wiesen mit allem was
dazugehört maß bindl und musik und setzt
das wetter gab sein bestes
eben nächsten jahr soll es dann endlich
wieder eine echte wiesn geben vermutlich
unter 3g bedingungen
schön wäre es jetzt bist du dran cent
mit fußball bundesliga aber vorher noch
eine goldmedaille ja denn bei den kanu
weltmeisterschaften in kopenhagen holte
konrad scheidner den titel der berliner
ließ im einer canadier über 1000 meter
der konkurrenz keine chance
mit seiner schwarz rot goldenen
bootsspitze liegt scheider in der ersten
rennhälfte im mittelfeld auf platz sechs
landete der 25-jährige berliner bei
olympia in tokio der deutsche
titelverteidiger sebastian brendel lässt
diese distanz hier diesmal zugunsten der
5000 meter strecke aus so kann sich
schreibt nur in diesem fahrwasser
bewähre nach bester renneinteilung fährt
er knapp vor dem tschechen martin fuchs
der im ziel umkippt so goldmedaille
dritter mit der ungar balazs adolf für
scheibner ist es der erste wm einzel
titel
in der fußball bundesliga haben die
bayern vorerst die tabellenspitze
übernommen der rekordmeister zerlegte
aufsteiger bochum mit sieben zu null
außerdem sorgte florian niederlechner
mit einem joker tor für einen späten
augsburger sieg gegen gladbach dazu zwei
torlose unentschieden zwischen mainz und
freiburg sowie bielefeld und hoffenheim
morgen noch drei weitere spiele und
gestern gewann die hertha zu hause gegen
aufsteiger führt in der tabelle kann
sich der vfl wolfsburg morgen platz eins
wieder zurückholen mit einem sieg gegen
frankfurt auch der bvb kann dann noch
klettern die härter macht nach zwei
siegen den größten sprung auf 9 in der
unteren tabellenhälfte zieht augsburg an
gladbach vorbei auf den abstiegsplätzen
bochum und führt im sportstudio ab 23
uhr 30 dann auf das abendspiel köln
gegen leipzig zu gast gladbachs lars
stindl
erfolg für triathletin laura lindemann
in der weltserie die olympia achte aus
potsdam gewann in hamburg über die
sprintdistanz passenderweise sprintete
sie auf den letzten 200 meter der
konkurrenz davon und kam als erster ins
ziel und deutlicher sieg für die
deutschen fußball frauen in der wm
qualifikation gegen bulgarien trafen
linda dallmann lehrer schüler und lina
wohl jeweils doppelt beim 7 0 in cottbus
damit führt das deutsche team seine
qualifikations-gruppe an am dienstag
heißt der nächste gegner serbien
übrigens im zdf
70 zweimal am tag das ist ja irre oder
mich für die gegner bestimmt zum schluss
noch ein vollendetes kunstwerk im
wahrsten wortsinn der betrieb in paris
ist jetzt fertig verpackt und verschnürt
und jeder darf ganz nah ran ans posthum
abgeschlossene projekt des verstorbenen
ehepaars christo auf tuchfühlung
sozusagen mit 25.000 quadratmetern stoff
das sonntagswetter verteilt sich nicht
wirklich gerecht die einen bekommen
sonne die anderen viele wolken oder
regen die details hat gleich katja
horneffer viertel nach elf begrüßt sie
marietta slomka im heute journal alles
gute ihnen ein schönes wochenende noch
und bis morgen wenn sie mögen auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten abend auch wenn das tief holen
schon ziemlich weit nach osten abgezogen
ist zusammen mit dem hoch jenny bringen
beide doch sehr kühle luft nach
mitteleuropa
deswegen war es heute auch sehr stark
bewölkt in nordosten warum ändert sich
was das die sven kommt heran zieht über
die westalpen weiter nach oberitalien
und jenny und das azorenhoch versuchen
eine brücke auszubilden heute also gab
es diese dichten wolken aus denen auch
ein bisschen regen fielen der gesamten
nordosthälfte im südwesten dagegen
strahlte die sonne und da es ist heute
nacht zum teil auch klar und es bildet
sich nebel die temperaturen dazu sinken
auf 13 grad an der nordsee und bis 6
grad am alpenrand das werden jetzt
richtig frische nächte und wo ist morgen
am sonnigsten ist sehen sie schon auf
unserer temperaturen karte denn zwischen
dem niederrhein und der donau steigen
die werte auf 19 bis 22 grad da wird es
dann nämlich auch am wärmsten richtung
nordosten und südwesten ist es bei 14
bis 17 grad kühler morgen sehen sie die
sonne wohl am meisten zwischen dem
sauerland und dem bayerischen wald aus
der schweiz heraus kommen dichtere
wolken die bringen auch regen mit und an
dieser wetter verteilung wird sich auch
am montag wenig ändern danach aber
beruhigt sich das wetter bei
temperaturen bis 22 grad schönes
wochenende